as we speak the Conclave of Cardinals is
meeting in Rome to elect the next pope
of the Roman Catholic Church the process
is shrouded in secrecy and rumors are
flying about who they will elect some
guys
strap in cuz it's time for some Pope
talk yeah let me get this straight
you're not you're not Catholic right
Andy no Conan but I'm a hell of a
handicap and if you ask me it's gonna be
somebody from Africa really Africa yep
I like Cardinal Peter Turkson from
heaven he's under 65 he's made no bones
about wanting the job and Africa is a
hot spot of Catholic grow up you were
out of your mind that's too big a swing
right now you're crazy they're
rebuilding you want to go back to basics
go with an Italian again like Angelo's
skull of Milan that's the guy to keep an
eye on here Angelo school was respected
I'm gonna pick an Italian okay Andy the
Pope retired that freaks people out they
want comfort food you give the hat to
Scola or at our Sacco Brittani puffs of
smoke
happy Easter everybody wins Haiti de
Haiti dough this is the Vatican my
friend they're not going backwards
grandpa
they are looking at Africa or the
Western Hemisphere like what mark will a
of Canada he's the head of the Vatican
Office for bishops he's an outsider he's
an insider this guy has got hat this
guy's got no hat the guy gets no respect
in his home Diocese of Quebec sure he's
popular in Latin America but if you want
that coat of Brazil's Odile Oh Sharon
you're out of your mind
he's 63 he's been on Twitter since 2011
too hip for the room on Frontline you
wanna bet y'all bet all right you know
what he's my pick I'm saying it now he's
a lock to win all right until we have a
caller on the line what's your question
hey Colin loved the show what do you
guys think of Cardinal Leonardo Sandra
well he's okay but you know if you want
to go with somebody from Argentina you
go with Jorge Mario bergoglio yeah he
came in second devoting when Benedict
took it all in 2005 yeah you guys think
Tim Dolan from New York has a shot oh my
god
waste our time talk to us
[Applause]
alright folks we're going to take a
break and don't forget next week Andy
and I will be talking Pope's live in the
hooters in Torrance California first 50
people get a mug and a beanie ladies
hey get your both painting
[Applause]